ja ich propagiere ja seit ungefähr zwei
jahren land eröffnet ab dass kinder frei
leben unter anderem ein lieblingsgericht
zusammen
kann man auch googeln ist eine kanaille
schwedische studie und die besagt dass
58,6 tonnen co2 eingespart werden können
wenn ich mich persönlich beispielsweise
nicht reproduziert hier haben wir die
anderen kleinen punkte weniger fliegen
weniger fleisch essen das ist halt alles
verschwindend gering im vergleich
tatsächlich hat diese studie dazu
geführt dass ich mich dann vor zwei
jahren entschieden habe nein ich werde
keine mutter das war nicht der einzige
gebunden ist sondern natürlich als
radikale feministin kann ich hoffentlich
den papieren interaktiv befolgen wenn
sie möchten kann ich ihnen erklären sie
können dann auch freuen nachdem sie bei
toxische möglichkeit schon verschenken
kann mir
gut der dritte punkt ist natürlich
gerade wir hatten ja schon die ganze
zeit die pandemie und so weiter und ich
frage mich jetzt schon corona bis 80 süß
ich denke mir irrsinnig muss ich
wirklich so sagen weil was für eine welt
ist dass das würde ich einem kind ich
bin so froh dass ich mich so entschieden
ab vor paar jahren ich bin jetzt 42 okay
ich habe regelmäßig blut
werde jetzt die letzte phase braucht man
es ja auch noch hinter mich bringen ja
das ist mein wunsch sagt sie finden ja
eigentlich frauen die jetzt ein kind
programm irrsinnig wenn ich sie richtig
und ich verlängere natürlich ja weil
jetzt gerade in der zeit kann man durch
dem kind nicht zumuten das ist diese
ganzen schulschließungen überhaupt keine
normale jugend und kindheit
habe ich jetzt
den krieg und diese klima gehabt dass
ich musste der bereich findet es dann
also nicht so gut sich jetzt zu
reproduzieren
eigentlich gesagt
aber das heißt ich finde es ganz
spannend würde also von so laut so
frauen ganz viel gewöhnt wenn ich sage
dass ich schwanger aber ganz viel machen
aber ich bin noch nie gefühlt also noch
keiner sagen
jetzt gibt's so kann man das frage ich
mich wie das bei solchen
das ist überhaupt kein ich freue mich
dass ich heute abend hier sind besonders
gerne übrigens weil ich schwanger bin zu
dem thema heute eingegangen war spannend
finde ich ziemlich mal zu fragen wie wie
in ihm das denn die eltern ihrer schüler
auf also sind ja auch lehrerin ich würde
mich jetzt wundern wenn mein kind später
also jetzt wird ja noch nicht so bald
zur schule gehen auf entschuldigen und
sagt ja die frau bot schweiger mama sie
hätten heute erzählt ich soll später
lieber keine kinder kriegen fürs klima
was mache ich ja natürlich nicht durch
das prison perfekt und was ich heute im
lehrplan zuvor finde also ich mehr da
komme ich logischerweise nicht mit
meinem privaten zeigt daher das ist klar
als publizist und boden und radikalsten
haben
als jetzt das was ich hier im bayrischen
liegen also noch haben sie haustiere ich
habe kein haus aufhängen klima
tiere sind die tiere ja sehr genau also
ich möchte auch die lebenden in der
wildnis zu hause sein denn tiere wie zum
beispiel giraffen elefanten und weiter
wir sind ja im ixs massensterben und
artensterben und ich möchte nicht dass
noch mehr tiere wegen uns menschen
aussterben ich meine wir sind so viele
milliarden
und das heißt dann immer so schön
habitat verlust na gut das heißt auf gut
deutsch das hat die menschen mal wieder
was zu betonieren den tieren wegnehmen
und ganze tierarten aussterben ich finde
aber diesen antrag prozent riss muss
sony nicht so gut ich bin im gegenteil
sogar grundfalsch und ich kann es nicht
mit meinem gewissen vereinbaren wie man
noch mehr konsumenten für den
kapitalismus hier aus wird die südliche
herausklappen zu lassen
und ja auch kommen ist geworden das
wissen wir ja gar nicht
nachvollziehen die argumentation von
frau wohnen schweiger nein ich muss
erstmal eine gewisse fassungslosigkeit
aus
denn ich habe noch nie einen menschen
getroffen der so traurig sein muss wie
sie und so an der welt verzweifelt ist
das ist nicht entschuldigen sowie das
ist nicht wenig trauer und wenig
traurigkeit feststelle ist das eine
feststellung meinerseits die ich dann
wohl vielleicht vermutet
in ordnung nein darum wie das ganze
mutter sind nicht dass letztendlich ihre
entscheidung aber es geht mir darum dass
sie praktisch eine absage an das
menschsein formulieren da kann ich auch
natürlich wenn sie dafür plädieren dass
keine kinder mehr auf die welt kommen
nein danke oder weniger das verbieten
was heißt das schon wieder das ist
weniger mehr wer liegt denn das fest ja
ich kann sagen das ist irrig was sie
machen mp der zynisch ignorant das
glaube ich habe bei ihnen nicht sondern
es ist eine besondere form ich kann sie
nicht nachvollziehen von egozentrik sie
können sie können doch von sich aus
die dann einen das menschsein die
menschliche entwicklung sie von 1 von 1
in das andere kind menschen kinder
kriegen sollen an denen sie wenig freude
haben haben sie sich mal vorgestellt
werden den gesellschafter aussieht die
sich zudem entschließt was mit denen
wird werden nur noch alte knochen
herumkriechen die ich und was nehmen sie
lacht aber dass ich freue mich
eigentlich verrückt aber ich hab noch
gefallen durchmachen nicht
wie sie unserem wunsch in das gesicht
dem unterordnen so perthes hat gesagt
wie sich ein sklave benimmt ist zu recht
ein sklave sich hat ihrer stelle wenn
sie aufrecht werden sie längst im
beamtenstatus verlassen aber sind also
ich würde meinen job gehen und es ist
halt auch mal sein sehen sie nicht dass
sie die hätte ich sagen machen
die opfer sind nein ich finde in ihrer
haltung
unglaublich macht mich sehr traurig und
wir fördern noch was anderes 1 kam einer
deutschen frau schon mal der deutschen
gesellschaft schon mal persönlichkeiten
die annahme ich nicht nennen möchte die
kinder und ab 30 versagt haben weil die
zukunft nichts bringe solchen wirklich
apokalyptischen und auch
menschenfeindlichen positionen kann ich
mich nicht
gegen monolog als jugendforscher fahren
wenn sie darauf auch blicken auf die
jugend wie sehen sie denn die these von
frau braunschweiger also ich kann es mir
möchte jetzt nicht gegen diese these
argumentieren die kann nur sagen ich
persönlich habe ein crooner kind
bekommen das ist jetzt zweieinhalb jahre
alt und macht mir wahnsinnig glücklich
und wie ich jetzt vor ort geflogen
werden zu sichern meinen fuß geklammert
und das war früher noch eine zehnjährige
tochter ich glaube das problem ist dass
wir dass da wirklich für mich wird
ausschließlich rational argumentiert
wird weil da geht es ja auch um gefühle
und emotionen und ein kind zu bekommen
da gebe ich schon recht nah thema
vernünftiges bekommen da war 60 ist
nicht unbedingt vernünftig aber es ist
macht mich glücklich und das ist macht
mein leben schöner und und ich glaube
das kind ist auch sehr glücklich alles
ist gut soziologisch betrachtet dieses
sodass wir sehen dass das bedürfnis nach
familie immer größer wird vor allem bei
jungen menschen und auch wieder nach
kindern also das erst mal hat den traum
eine wirklich eine funktionierende
familie zu haben kinder in die welt zu
setzen auf möglichst aufs land zu ziehen
und dort glücklich und friedlich zu
leben und und die finde es irgendwie ist
verwundert mich auch nicht wenn sie
sagen wenn sie auch diese welt ist so
herausfordernd und so schwierig geworden
und es ist so viel wettbewerb und so
viel gelesen ja ich möchte einen raum
haben wo ich mich zurückziehen kann und
einfach glücklich sein kann und der
bibel in harmonie leben kann und ich
glaube das ist das wichtige das heißt
wenn die familie so nüchtern betrachtet
dann wird man einfach dem den den diesen
diesen dieser kultur dieser familien
kultur und das ist dieser emotionalen
kultur nicht gerecht
ihre meinung also
erst mal ich habe drei kinder und eben
noch total glücklich seit juli ende juni
zum 18 17 habe ich meine erste
enkeltochter gekriegt ich das total
super und ich kann ihnen auch berichten
meine tochter ist wirklich fröhlich und
glücklich also das wirklich das etwas
irrationales sie sind ja noch ja ich
kann das nicht
so richtig habe glaube ich musste ja
ich muss auch sagen ich arbeite lieber
dafür will ich gegen den klimawandel
arbeiten will arbeite ich lieber dafür
im parlament scharfe regeln und rahmen
dass wir ein besseres klima sozusagen in
den griff bekommen und gehen nicht zu
solchen irrationalen moment lieber und
entscheidet sich dann wieder keiner geht
hin dass studien die frau braunschweiger
recht gehen sagen nicht wegen dem klima
noch nie sagen kinderlos ist man
glücklicher und auch publizistinnen die
sagen kinder sind ein freiheits keller
also ich glaube nicht dass man da
glücklicher sein kann frauchen ist
glaube ich einfach nicht weitergehen ein
so viel und kinder bekam von kindern
auch wieder lernen und das ist genau das
was hier völlig außer acht gelassen wird
und insofern finde ich es gut dass sie
frau braunschweiger wenn wir jetzt
darauf blicken uns die anderen meinung
die hier emotional
hier die typischen deutschen es tut mir
leid männer meinungen und die typischen
klischees ich kann schon beschrieben sie
nicht aber die drei herren
darf medienrummel ich konnte trotzdem
wenn ich es ist eine botschaft die sie
vielleicht wissen wenn ich sage oh shit
vinco spielen wenn ich hier wieder
menschenfeindlich auch keine kinder ist
nicht zukunftsorientiert
das genaue gegenteil ist ja schließlich
der fall und ich zum beispiel merke ich
immer diesen tiefen nazismus bei eltern
es muss mein kind sein und meine schönen
blauen augen muss ich verehren und weil
jemand adoptieren wir haben 3000 kinder
zum beispiel im weißen haus in der
schweiz bei der völlig einer aktion
gewesen johanna version die können
bleiben wo der pfeffer weg sollte die
interessiert sich keiner nein ich muss
unbedingt da dieses minimieren anke
amerikanischen wir waren haben sich
jederzeit wenn ihnen die frage nicht so
persönlich ist natürlich habe er
dienstlich viele kinder und kinder von
freunden verbunden ich habe schon es
müssen nicht meine eigenen kinder seien
so ein narzisst und egoist bin ich halt
nicht
es gibt auch studien die sagen dann wird
die mutiger mit kindern und weniger
egoistisch weil mir natürlich für die
kinder sich zurücknimmt und das geht ja
immer noch um ein selber weil ohne mich
gehts ja das klingt gar nicht also das
ist schon eine eine sehr nützliche sache